[Music]
hello plastic pills listeners
this is victor i'm joined by my fellow
left lib compatriot matt mcmanus
bringing you a treat of an interview
today
benjamin teitelbaum is assistant
professor of ethnomusicology and
international affairs at the university
of colorado boulder
he is a scholar and ethnographer of
contemporary radical nationalism in
europe and globally title bomb's first
book titled lines of the north music and
the new nordic radical nationalism
examined the role that traditional
scandinavian folk music as well as some
other genres played in
new radical nationalist movements to
accomplish this research title bomb
mastered the swedish
language and embedded himself with
several ethnonationalist groups
one reviewer called the book an
open-minded quest to understand his
interlocutors
rather than undermining their cause he
takes their fears grievances and
concerns seriously without trivializing
or denying the harmful effects of their
racist and xenophobic resentments
such an approach is i believe urgently
important for left-wing intellectuals in
our contemporary polarized moment
title bomb's second book which is the
focus of this podcast is
war for eternity inside bannon's
far-right circle of global power brokers
though interestingly i think the
european market has a different subtitle
which i actually think maybe is better
uh the return of traditionalism and the
rise of the populist right
so in the book title bomb engages with
the still not very well known capital t
traditionalist philosophy connected to
several uh recent global far-right
figures
including alexander dugan yair bolsonaro
and steve bannon
the latter which title bomb managed to
score over 20 hours of interviews with
glenn greenwald called it an
indispensable text for understanding the
most profound and tumultuous political
shifts defining
uh societies on every continent i agree
the book manages to shift effortlessly
between nuanced ethnographic and
theoretical reflection
and exciting journalistic non-fiction
narrative honestly listeners if you have
any interest in our political moment and
some of the underlying political theory
picked this book up
it was a joy to read or listen to in my
case i'll also say reading about
traditionalist concerns and grievances
i've never felt more like a globalist i
feel maybe i want to reclaim that term
also as we're recording now just a
couple days ago
trump supporters stormed the capital so
it feels somewhat appropriate to be
having this interview
anyway i'm very excited for this
conversation benjamin title bomb welcome
to the show
it's a pleasure to be with you both yeah
thanks a lot for coming on uh i really
enjoyed your book so i just wanted to
start with that but
uh before i get into the kind of
substance of what you were
saying in this new text i was just
wondering so what prompted you to look
at politics initially
as an ethnomusicologist
i was in sweden to do my dissertation
research
as a graduate student i was going to
write a dissertation on
asymmetrical rhythm in swedish folk
music
and i promise you it would have been a
good dissertation no one would have
cared or read it but it would have been
very a very accurate
study anyway so i'm over there to do
something very very narrow
and in music theoretical actually more
than ethnomusicological which is the
study of music and culture
and while i'm there the sweden democrats
enter
parliament um this is 2010
fall of 2010 and in the lead-up to that
they announced their announcing
initiatives of course they're known
by most people as an anti-immigrant
nationalist xenophobic
force in swedish politics the type that
the country had prided itself on keeping
out of its parliament for
uh you know since since the the war era
essentially
distinguishing sweden in the european
context that's how most people thought
about them but they
they came out ahead of that election and
said you know what one of our first
initiatives will be
to try and funnel funding to swedish
folk music
and i thought okay well that's kind of
you know suddenly there's some political
relevance i hate the term but to
to what i'm studying and so i decided to
probe it through a couple of interviews
and i could go deeper into why that
appealed to me i actually at the time i
was doing research i was i was somewhat
resentful
of what i thought was appraising of the
ethnographic subject that i had been
taught
in graduate school that okay we're going
to go out and we're going to study the
world and we are going to love the
people who we study
and i i never liked that and i always
thought well this
this isn't this just so contingent on
you studying the right people
so how about i go study people i don't
like and that that story takes a number
of twists and turns of course but
um so i went and did those interviews
and the more i learned you know i saw
that that
that momentary really a facade
interest in folk music from some sexers
of some parties
in in swedish uh radical right-wing
activism
was telling a much larger story it was
about the reform of the radical right it
was about
impr increasing confidence on part of
this political cause that actually there
were
political dividends to be reaped uh were
they to reform themselves that they
actually were not
complete pariahs facing hopeless chances
in electoral
politics and if they did the right
things they could actually lay claim to
the future
all of that was baked into this one
moment and and the
deeper i looked it it seemed that the
interest in folk music was part of a
broader push
involving a number of different
expressive forms to get away from a
skinhead
stereotype and a skinhead profile as
part of this push to reform so that
that got me started the ethnographic
experience i found
stimulating and challenging in a good
way
and and since then i've i've continued
to study at any time
anytime that music is part of the
subject i think that's great if it's not
part of the subject i don't
i don't say that it's off limits to me
and i keep studying it cool
yeah i thought that a lot when i was
reading your new book in part because
i did my own fair share of social
science research back in the day and
almost all of it was about marginalized
communities that you tend to have a fair
bit of sympathy for
you know a lot of welcome families
people with legal problems and
you know you usually feel pretty bad for
what's going on and you empathize with
what's happening
uh reading this new book and listening
to some of the people uh naturally as a
left-wing guy i kind of thought to
myself
like i would struggle to hold myself
back
and to try to just let the material
speak for itself in the way you did so i
applaud that
i guess like the first substantive
question i had and then move on to
victors
is i'm interested personally and how it
is that you conceive of this philosophy
or ideology of traditionalism
so we've seen that world throw it around
a lot in a variety of different contexts
in your book as victor said it's kind of
capital t traditionalism
and you define it in a number of
different ways throughout the text
and you know that's very uh consistent
with the fact that many of the adherents
of so-called traditionalism
adopt a different perspective uh on it
and so one of the things i wanted to ask
you is
is there kind of a unifying feature to
capital t traditionalism what does it
stand for
uh or is it so highly localized as a
kind of reaction against modernity
that there's nothing that really unites
it except a kind of visceral distaste
for
you know cars and topless women or
whatever it happens to be right
this is this is a wonderful and informed
question and one
one sign of that is that i actually
can't give you i'm not gonna be able to
give you a straight answer
certainly uh there are no pro-modernity
traditionalists that i have ever met
so we can say that an initial
qualification is is the belief that
modernity
is is a particular pest brought to
humanity
and and how one deals with that is is
another question but
if if we look at the basics uh
it in its most theorized and especially
i would say in its original
texts um traditionalists would not agree
of course that there are there
an original text but let's leave that
aside uh let's say in renegade who is
this
this french philosopher the belief is
french traditionalist philosopher really
the patriarch of the movement the belief
is is that once upon a time
there was a true religion in the world
the ur
tradition capital t and
we happen to live in a universe where as
time goes on things get worse
opposite the values of progress and
modernity and
modernity and modernism that we're that
we're otherwise used to thinking
through uh and
following that that ur tradition has
been
degraded as time has gone on it's become
lost to us it's been fragmented
splintered and all these various
traditions
and the best that we could hope for is
to find
some bastardized fragmentary piece of it
and devote ourselves to it completely
and maybe we can use it as a channel as
a keyhole
to peer through into what once was
um if we start at that very simple level
uh as i say it sets us up to not be
especially invested in campaigns for
emancipation
to not believe in progress to not
believe that we could create a world
that is fundamentally better than one
that has ever existed in the past
that's very general it's very vague but
it's enough
to make us anti-liberal right
assuming assuming that we want to have
uh that we believe that that politics
plays a role in these in these deeper
questions if it's not just about
you know i don't know perhaps you think
that that single payroll
single-payer healthcare and universal
health coverage is a good thing as i do
uh perhaps someone treats that as a
surface
level concern but in the big picture of
things big scheme
we uh we're not going to be a
traditionalist and be a progressive and
a liberal
beyond that you start to see a lot of of
fragmentation and what i focus on in
this book
is is really rightist traditionalism or
political traditionalism as
a one thinker charles upton asked me to
call it who's a traditionalist who's
very much against the figures that i
that i study in the book but uh to say
that it
uh traditionalism belonging in the
lineage of this proto-fascist
philosopher julius evela is
as traditionalism that that's kind of a
helpful doctrine to me and in that case
we're not just talking about an
opposition to modernity and a belief
that
the past was better in a sort of worship
of precedence
but we're talking about uh fairly
specific
invocations of the hindu caste hierarchy
belief in a time cycle which i think is
so so important to a lot of the
political movements that we see
associated with traditionalism
around the world today a belief that we
are in a process of decline and that we
have to go into destruction in order to
get
back to a rebuilding of of glory that
once was
um those that's where you see the
fragmentation but even even there even
among those
individuals who follow julius cevilla
there there's a lot of variation
in terms of of people who take those
those directives and those
characterizations as literal almost
spiritual truths
and others who such as alexander dugan
said to me
he said that well i take them as
signposts
you know they're just kind of guidelines
and i do i do what i want with it
so so yes we have to characterize
traditionalism as encompassing all of
that
it certainly aids and makes
makes variation easier when you don't
have an actual traditionalist creed when
you don't have traditionalist
organizations or
that many outlets there's not that sort
of organizational
infrastructure but i would certainly
encourage any any listeners to
to ponder also the fact that a lot of
ideologies
work in this way yeah um
look at look at the recent history even
just the the 20th century history of
marxism um
and how fragmented and you know how
sectarian that belief system has been in
latin america or you know
it's this is more the standard for for
intellectual history and political
mapping
and and organizational uh
mapping than than not cool yeah i was
going to say i think
victor and i as a political legal
theorist right we sometimes like to say
well there has to be
an inner coherence to these movements
right uh otherwise they're not real
ideologies or they're not real marxism
or not real traditionalism
and that's not really the way these
things are when you actually set them in
the wild
and people start to make of them what
they will um because
what's really fascinating to me in the
book is just how varied some of these
opinions are from a kind of
geopolitical standpoint i mean you have
people who are very pro-china people are
very
pro-usa like steve bannon you have
people who
have quasi-racial uh ideas of how it is
that nature works
uh versus christian universalists right
people who really believe in this kind
of
religious outlook that unites all
humankind the one sense that i did get
for that kind of unites everybody is
this idea that actually these are very
mundane concerns uh in a certain respect
next to this spiritual narrative of
decline
that seems to unite all of them that
seem to be the one constant at least to
me
but i'll let victor take over there that
was just well if you want to say
something about that
um no no i agree with that completely
okay awesome
yeah and actually one one observation i
made uh when i was while listening to
your book was
um that there and this is a pattern i i
often see
there's like you know political thinkers
who are trying to get the public on
board and to some extent i suppose
bannon is somebody who's trying to
like you know um like rally a movement
or was trying to rally a movement but
you know there's it almost seemed to me
like there was like an exoteric
and then an esoteric like so you know to
get the public on board like sort of the
elevator pitch
that that would be often related to
grievance politics so things talking
about like look at what's happening to
these things but it's like the actual
members of the public
you know they don't like know that much
like they don't know traditionalist
philosophy they don't understand these
things so i wonder
like it i you know one thought i had
when i was reading it it almost reminded
me of scientology it's like they they
pull you in with these like self-help
things but then they
you don't know about like the mystical
underpinnings of it and it's like that
doesn't even seem that important for
convincing the public it's like
you just need the grievance and i wonder
how you see that
absolutely it's it's one we can start at
the beginning
and look and say that okay so
traditionalism this political
traditionalism that i've
studied in the book it overlaps with
right-wing populism
and with just plain conservatism quite a
bit i get to that at the end of the book
one thing i regret is that i should have
kind of put that observation right up
front
but it overlaps so much that you you
really
and it's almost it's it's really too
early to tell you can't always tell well
are these people genuine because there
is always the possibility that
traditionalism is the fancy language for
people who
are populists but don't like the idea of
themselves being populists
and as as i see it if we take the
ideologies
seriously and we and we take their
prescriptions seriously
we should see we would see people
showing their colors let's say in the
united states sewing whether they're
a libertarian tea party or
activist or a nationalist um a statist
kind of nationalist after they have
done their desired destruction uh rested
it upon the us government
uh do is there an absence of government
after that or is there the creation of a
new state that they think is better
showing that they're they're really not
against government per se just the one
that we have at this moment
uh though there are those tipping points
flash points to be found uh throughout
the scheme and especially if you think
about a political ideology reaching
maturation
to the extent such a thing makes sense
um
and and and again we can't we can't
answer that that question right now
one thing though that we we can at least
ponder and i and i think it's
i think it's a helpful intellectual
exercise to do this if nothing else
is what is the role of racism you
mentioned
grievances uh victor is it possible
would
we ever want to say that racism is the
exoteric
is the selling point of something deeper
so often when you
when you look at politics especially
mainstream politics in the west
i'm used to encountering for my
colleagues the claim that okay well this
you know people are talking about moving
to a nice neighborhood and oh and you
know stay away from the hooligans and
the thugs and we don't want the welfare
queens
um that you have all this language uh
dressing up racial resentment
and in bannon's case who has been a race
baiter and and
breitbart has has been this uh you know
bent
over backwards to accommodate the causes
of identitarians and white nationalists
uh throughout
throughout his his leadership of it and
and and since
you you at least confront the idea well
what if the racism
is actually concealing something else
i'm not sure that's true
of course but it's a helpful
intellectual exercise for for
those of us who are trying trying to get
a deeper understanding of what
what is going on right now and certainly
that would really surprise a lot of
people i have to say
yeah yeah if you thought on those terms
and it doesn't mean that that's
that's true maybe i i'm i lean more in
the direction of thinking that
traditionalism gives us you know gives
these people cover
and justification for for something that
might be more
more plain but i don't know i don't know
it requires a degree of
of of mind reading that that i'm not
comfortable with as a scholar
i might be as a journalist but not as a
scholar yeah for sure
and actually um you know it that makes
me think about
another another thought i had which was
i was wondering what kind of in both the
process of writing uh war for eternity
as well as your previous work
um spending time with all these people
um
you know obviously there's a variety of
different kinds of nationalism
uh between the two books i'm sure but
like did you make any sort of
psychological
observations of of people because one
one thing
i've i've noticed when i encounter
people who are really like
um politically engaged and politically
mobilized like very partisan
and there's like a lot of emotions
behind it usually
and um i've often you know i once took a
class uh
when i was doing my masters it was like
a super woke class uh
awesome it was about like prisoner
prisoner justice reform like really
interesting moral questions about like
you know what's the justification for
keeping um
you know keeping prison the prison
industrial complex but i just noticed
that a lot of my classmates you know who
were very involved in that world
they were less interested in the
intellectual exercise and more
interested in in being angry
at the system you know and like and it
almost felt more like a group therapy
session than it did like you know a a a
class
and i would imagine you might observe
something similar uh
with really politically uh and i guess
the the insight that i often had was
you know is this a like is your anger a
symptom of something
else inside you know like something
personal you know i
i i don't find anger that interesting
it might be yeah i guess i guess shame i
guess anger is almost like an offshoot
of shame sometimes
where am i i can tell you where my
thoughts are going at least victor i'm
i'm thinking about
certainly people who the term is
disenfranchised but i i would rather it
be more social and
and psychological than that but people
who feel powerless
um violated like they've had something
taken from them
and that it was unjust
that can br i've seen that of course
produce anger
that's that's the most intelligible
response to that but
equal of equal note and for most of my
scholarly career this has been the
dominating predominant response from
traditionalists people in that in that
sector of the rock riot
it's it's also produced despondency
um you know that that narrative that
okay we've lost the future
the future is in ours i've lost the
public sphere i've lost
the public debate we've lost the
mainstream um
my identity the way i'm going to live
out my radical rightness
is by commemorating and mourning
defeat if i could just interject there
as
and yeah carry on uh one of the examples
of that that came up
really prominently is there was a kind
of pure technical quality to some of the
traditionalists that you interviewed but
what really fascinated me is this could
be juxtaposed in other instances
by this almost hedonistic embrace of
things like drugs and alcohol culture
uh sex you know which seemed to really
reflect what you were talking about not
to mention
uh more kind of post-modern iterations
of despondency you're talking about you
know
irony trolling just trying to get a rise
out of people would you say that's
kind of reflective of that yes yes of a
say levy
uh sort of sort of dismissal yes i one
of the concepts i really wanted to write
about i did write about in a draft and
it got cut
was was you know what i call right-wing
melancholia
you know which is this i think i think
it saturates
a lot of different areas of their
activism
this it's it's a it's a heidigarian
sense of being in the world that this is
the way that the way that i relate to
things
is by divesting myself of of of any hope
for their future
disavowing any obligation to participate
in the creation of a better society
because it's lost
um we might we might speak about that
more colloquially as
a martyr complex of course right
predominant but
i think it i think it's deeper than that
because because the way that it's
it's celebrated um you know the the use
of hallucinogenics
in in the radical right and i think in
this in this
sector of the radical right has a number
of roots it also
also speaks to their belief that you
know a materialistic worldview or the
world that we see
is not the real world and that you can
access a deeper spiritual world that's
beyond the reaches of managerial
liberalism
uh through through experimentation uh
and
and through through altering your
consciousness in various ways through
spirituality or through drugs
um yeah i can go on about this a long
time
i have a big article coming out about
this soon oh cool i absolutely like to
read it because i thought that was
really interesting right just because
you see these kinds of you see the sense
of reprobation that sometimes takes
place amongst these people right where
uh they're lamenting the fact that
they've been corrupted by this modern
world like you're talking about how it
is that they're
almost desperately trying to get back to
something that they feel has been taken
away from
them but then in other instances their
response to it seems to be to
not embrace modern hedonism but to
almost uses an
outlet for all these energies and all
this animosity that they're not able to
channel in any other effective direction
right
and you know matthew i i even see that i
i see that less is a theorized response
from from some of these figures and more
just as a
as a palpable fact of their existence if
you watch them
um you know steve bannon in the word
piety
could barely that just they he's you
know swears more than anyone i've ever
met
more colorful uh you know
vocabulary profanities than just about
anyone i've ever met in my life
um indeed some conservative actors in
scandinavia that i know very well need
very hedonistic lives more so than i've
ever seen
no that's interesting so and it's it's
not theorized but but yes this
this uh dismissal of decorum some some
might even say
uh you know rejection of society um
refusal to
to invest in social norms with the
belief that doing so is going to make
your life
better in some way that key conservative
impulse is is missing for the person
who's much more fatalistic and is in
and does not care about maintaining
what's good about society now because
with society right now
there is nothing good to it that gets
distilled in traditionalism in a way
that it's it's really just an element or
latent in other
other ultra conservative ideas and
conservative ideas about
yeah for sure so i was you know i think
i was thinking before about like um
sort of related to the exoteric esoteric
distinction
um you know that i think people who
get attracted to these ideas i wonder
and maybe you spent less time talking to
like you know people who are like you
know who i don't know if you've explored
much
the youtube under underworld of of
traditionalism and all these youtubers
and i feel like the followers often i've
talked to some of them
uh there's there there tends to be the
type of people who don't feel very
comfortable in their own skin i suppose
and this
like you know this they get pulled in by
something that
is an answer for them about like why
they're feeling that way
and i guess maybe that's what i was
thinking about before more than anger is
not exactly the right way to articulate
it right it's just like people who
feel like there's something missing in
their lives and it's like those are the
people that bannon wants to get in
to his uh into his tent
or whatever the rootless young white men
who play video games
exactly incels that's how he's put it in
the past
and i've heard yeah i mean if it doesn't
i don't want to say rank and file
traditionalists because that implies a
sort of again an organizational
structure that doesn't exist
but i one interview i conducted with an
activist from from northern europe
uh a traditionalist as well he noted
he said that you know you don't
socialize we don't socialize because
we're all
you know we're all pretty messed up and
a lot of us commit suicide and we're
some of us are so depressed
uh you know that the the spark really
you know for him he was saying one great
moment was september 11th
all right modernity is crashing this is
going and then
no it didn't stop it in his mind nothing
nothing ever we're not we're not on some
downward trajectory no we're
[ __ ] up yeah we're still heading in
the same direction
um and yeah it's [ __ ] up but think
think it if that's the sort of
if that's the sort of event that it
takes to make you feel hopeful
yeah that's pretty messed up for sure
think about think about what life is
going to be like
um there are other ways when i've
observed that too
i've i've been trying to write an
article on death in june for a long time
you know death and junas
no i'm afraid i don't know okay kind of
pseudo adjacent to traditionalism
neo-folk music
uh apropos everything we were saying
before about divesting from society i
think it is
very important that death in june does
not sing with words
in many cases there's a lot of in this
music because
why say anything what's the point um
and and there are some people who who
tie this to traditionalism to julius
cevilla to riding the tiger
but i always wanted to speak to more and
it is so hard for me to get people to
speak to me
from this segment i can get neo-nazi
white nationalist white power
right-wing populist anyway but this
sector they don't speak to each other
and they don't speak to me
and and probably this last book is not
going to help me much
but uh but but i think i think that has
more to do it has to do with more than
just
just me just an outside researcher with
a jewish last name
hmm interesting so actually um you made
me think of something too uh
i wonder maybe it's worth mentioning the
connection between
traditionalism and accelerationism which
is something we talk about with our
like sometimes because but usually we'll
talk about it in the context of
left-wing accelerationism right like you
know
you know more tamer versions you know we
hear brianna greyjoy or joy gray i
forget talking about you know we need to
destroy the democratic party to
start it up and i wonder if you could
speak to the the form of accelerationism
in traditionalism
absolutely because i think these
incidentally overlap and really they
speak to a
to probably a deeper drive among among
dissidents
but yes if if traditionalists on the
right
as many of them do believe that we live
in a time cycle
and that life is destined to be this bad
it needs to get
worse before this dark age the kali yuga
as hinduism puts it reaches its climax
society implodes
and then we are reborn into a golden era
and decline will the cycle of decline
begins again
if if that's our fate you really
shouldn't
in the doctrine arise want to go
backwards because going backwards isn't
possible the only thing you can do is go
forward you need to embrace destruction
and this
this is you know part of the treachery i
think inherent in right-wing
traditionalism
that has to be spoken about in plain
terms
and uh you know so what does that mean
though
we're still speaking you know in in
quite
quite vague terms does that mean that
steve bannon
should join the green party and become
a you know an lgbtq activist and
you know or does it mean you you get
trump and destroy the u.s federal
government
or try all those options are there now
there are some eccentric cases there are
alternatives to that they're
they have to be described as that
alternative uh brands of traditionalism
that say no actually you you do have a
role to play you can push things
backwards
julius evela notably thought that he was
seeing a reversal of the time
time cycle so that's not an
accelerationist doctrine but
um but for most of them
destruction is how you move forward and
and the direction breeds creation i
guess yes destruction beats creation i
mean
the distinction here is that they're
going out of their way to add a sort of
spiritual
religious eschatology behind that what
might otherwise be a sort of secular
practical reality
impulse yesterday maybe it was i was
just going to say yeah i mean do you
think yesterday too that that
traditionalists are celebrating or i
guess it was the day before yesterday
or i mean it seems like in the public
opinion it's looking like a failure in a
bit of the end of trumpism but we'll see
it's a bit early
absolutely absolutely i it's i've been
this partially what i've been trying to
do these past days to keep really close
tabs on it steve
bannon is basically useless to listen to
at the moment
on this because i think he is still
vying for a need some sort of pardon
from trump or some intervention
in his legal situation in the few days
that that are left january 19th yep
exactly and and and so i
ahead of that time i don't think we're
going to hear a lot of criticism of of
trump or celebration of
of trump's destruction coming from from
steve bannon but others who
who i follow um i haven't spoken with
anyone
you know they loved the rebellion they
loved the chaos
of it um for different reasons one
person said this is the closest that the
united states has ever come
to a working-class uh revolt or
revolution
and the left will never see that um at
the very least
there's not a lot of disappointment uh
over what what happened yesterday
uh wednesday excuse me actually that
segues really nicely into
uh mike two questions so um these are
two interrelated ones and i'll try to be
as brief as possible like one is that
like
the kind of world view to the extent
that you can characterize it as a
philosophy
uh that you see espoused by a lot of
these people is really unlike what you'd
expect to see
from somebody who is brought up in leo
in
liberal modernity in the sense that it's
extremely totalizing
right like vastly totalizing uh you know
in some senses
i almost thought to myself when i was
reading this like hegel would be put to
shame by like
how this tries to incorporate everything
into it right yes uh and
it was struck me that a lot of times if
you kind of try to
give some intellectual coherence to this
in the way that we academics might it
doesn't make a lot of sense
but it does offer a kind of explanatory
grid uh that incorporates
tons of stuff not just the material
world but as you put it like the extra
material world
into it uh and the second thing that i
wanted to ask you related to that is
while i was reading this i was thinking
about some of our listeners and thinking
and pondering that one of the kind of
big picture doctrines that they might
have gravitated towards for this kind of
totalizing explanation
was classical or orthodox marxism which
does have a kind of big picture view of
society
and yet most the people that you see
here aren't really all that interested
in teams and economic issues sometimes
they are like steve bannon uh he had
that kind of wonderful narrative
uh where he was uh in the south midwest
and somebody threw him a coors and he
doesn't drink now but you know
there's kind of a symbology to that
right uh he wasn't being given a crap
here he was giving you
a good you know beer that you can get an
american
good american beer you can get any gas
station um
but you know he talks a little bit about
yeah we need to help the working class
we need to you know have a working class
with vault
but they don't really just seem that
interested in economic issues in the
sense that they want to completely
remake the capitalist order at least not
to the same extent you see with
classical marxists for whom
political economy is absolutely central
it almost always seems subordinated to
the spiritual
idea cultural yeah yes yes and yeah it's
just one if you could
mince this a little bit because i mean i
mean the distinction
what was interesting about steve bannon
is that it and where we see the
distinctions there's there's a sort of
causality
um inversion let's say with most with
most traditionalists i mean
you're certainly right to say that
traditionalist
traditionalism is generally
disinterested in material inequalities
because it's disinterested in material
period
it's disinterested money goods bodies uh
if if we take it at face value um
and and the reason for that disinterest
is is a devotion to the spiritual or the
or the immaterial
bannon had an odd little take on this
where he says that really spiritual
vitality
is is the most important thing we could
possibly do collective spiritual
vitality is
is what this is all about well how do we
get there well
suddenly starts talking about economics
again yeah
um and and and sovereignty and order i
mean
economics really being being though a
regis a register of social order but
nonetheless the
if we just focus on economics and
spirituality for a moment
there's there's i mean
spirituality is secondary to to to
materialism in that in that sense for
him
um it is the result the byproduct of of
a more enlightened of a more virtuous
material set of relations we're mixing
with a
lot of things here and i'm not i'm not a
scholar of marxism to the extent that
i can comment on if you know
to what extent that appears in other
strains of marxism marx wasn't against
spirituality per se of course
he was against it as a uh as a
as obscuring um in excusing
and preventing any sort of change to to
an unjust
uh set of material relations uh but
the distinction i would see with steve
is just just the
the emphasis on on on spirituality
really being in the center that that is
that is
the absolute goal um yes i'll put it
yeah i'll put this on a different way
um that's a little bit less like
academicky right because
i guess this is what i was really
getting at you know you're
21 to say 35 year old white dude you
know in the basement that bannon wants
to reach
he's playing video games uh he's got a
job at chuck e cheese but he's still
living with his mom because he can't pay
his bills
why would he embrace donald trump rather
than somebody like bernie sanders or why
would he embrace
bannonis traditionalism rather than aoc
uh you know universal healthcare all the
kind of things that a good
liberal socialist roles in like me
thinks
we should have and would help that
person yeah what do you think about them
materially you know
yeah yeah what what do you what do you
get from trump that you don't get from
from bernie national nationalism
national identity
you know i i think if if we wanted to
add to that
we would say embeddedness
meaning uh spiritual meaning
a connection to history um
uh feeling embedded in history that
you're you know
not simply lost at sea in this in this
uh
in this world of progress um
now bannon doesn't like to use the word
identity a lot we've we've had a number
of conversations with them but that's
i don't know what else i would call it
yeah
um uh an archaic identity a pre
an extra rational identity or like thick
culture or something
sure yeah yes we could come up with
probably
a number of ways to say that but it
makes a lot of sense yeah okay
so i was i was also curious uh maybe
backing up a bit more to sort of
questions of methodology i'm sort of
interested in
the ethnographic method and maybe you
this could even go back to your earlier
work
um just kind of curious of how like what
that's like
um maybe if you're explaining to
somebody who doesn't know what
ethnography is
um like like what that's about and i'd
just be interested in
um what like how was that experience for
you the first time you started hanging
out with
you know an ethno-nationalist i just
kind of want to know what that was like
for you and what you did to
kind of maintain um you know
loyalty or not loyalty but i guess
consistency with ethnography and what
you're trying to what you were trying to
accomplish
i had this imaginative scenario where
you know you just went up to the bar and
you're like
hey let's grab a beer you know so how
about you know uh you know the jewish
problem let's start there
what are your thoughts on the jewish
problem uh it was
it was hard and it it's changed a lot as
as years have
gone by i i really started
again what the standard for ethnography
that i as as i
understood it was i mean you you go out
in the field and you form relationships
with people that's
that's ethnography is key resource it's
like investigative journalism but but
deeper and more dialogical
and all of the theory it was mostly
framed in moralistic
terms was that okay you're going to meet
these people and by the way you're going
to share authorship with them
and you're going to empower them and
you're going to adopt their definitions
of themselves because
the goal of ethnography is is to really
learn
to see and interpret the world through
the eyes of the of the people you're
studying
and and yes this is all good because
because they're good people right and we
like them
that's the unstated uh subtext to this
all but
anyways that's that's how a lot of a lot
of the theory went
um my first my first thought was that's
dumb
and i actually all the
all the observations about the
limitations of objective knowledge and
objectivity notwithstanding i think that
objectivity is
is a is a valuable ideal so let's drive
toward it i'm gonna
i'm gonna study these people it's gonna
be dispassionate there's gonna be no
love letters
and um and and you know i'm going to be
this old-fashioned ethnographer so i
went and i talked to them
it was it was actually easy for me to
talk about say the jewish question
because i was
kind of disciplined with myself and
saying the purpose of you speaking to
this person
is not to settle the score on whether or
not immigration
is good and by the way i'm not
interested in the question of whether
jews are good
or they know cost happen these are not
engaging questions for me so why am i
going to spend time on them
stronger man than me i got to i would
have been able to do it
to well and and
and there are other there are other
places for it i'm pretty opinionated
otherwise that might have
helped me that to kind of
compartmentalize and it helped that it
was sweden and scandinavian not the
united states
i would have had a really hard time back
during the obama administration doing
this type of work with the tea party
movement
it's you know there's a difference when
it's your home society but anyway so i
had that
i had the distance going in other words
um
you know an old-fashioned ethnographer
objective or at least striving towards
it
accepting it as an ideal um
the thing is
all of that that precious sweet sappy
sounding
uh theory i was just talking about if we
even want to call it that that you need
to
be collaborating with the people you
study you need to work together to
understand how they
how they see the world and you need to
surrender some authority you need to be
in dialogue you cannot monopolize
uh the conversation it i came
to think and and i came to think
eventually quite strongly that
the justifications for that are not only
moral
they're also epistemological that is to
say that they are also
good because they teach us more um
they they build empathy in the sense
that empathy is distinct from sympathy
and to the extent that empathy is
knowledge not a stance
um not an edict or an endorsement or
lack thereof but instead simply knowing
more about what it's like to see the
world through someone else's eyes
in order to do that you had to sustain
fairly good relationships and a product
of sustaining good relationships and
having a lot of contact of course is
that you get to know people and you
start to see them as being more
than just one thing you see them as
gosh what's here's an example i mean
steve bannon uh
steve bannon has a daughter with liver
disease i have a daughter with i have a
daughter with liver disease
we have a lot of conversation a lot of
conversations off the record about that
the hell do i do with that some of those
conversations were really
uh very very important to me
um it does that mean that does that
absolve
anything does that mean that i want to
go out and and make them a cover for
his his political ideology certainly not
but i'm not going to be able to speak
about him in the ways that i would
had i maintained distance and it's real
knowledge about the actual person who's
there
so um so things get complicated in other
words it's not
just the political ideals it's that it's
that
you have to grapple with more
information
and i've had you may know i mean i've
had a lot of discussions with people
about the ethics
of this of this method not just doing it
but how do you write about it
and you know i i i go back and forth
there are things i've written
and things i've thought that i i no
longer stand behind but
the underlying principle that i still
embrace is that
it is better to to grapple with the
information that is there
if my conclusions about someone are
going to be dependent upon my not
knowing them
well enough or not knowing certain
things about them i'm not sure that i
want those conclusions
and i'm going to be very suspicious of
people who who can only sustain their
conclusions
if they keep keep distance um
so i feel like i've spun off a little
bit here no no that's good i mean i love
that answer
i love that answer so much i mean i
that's actually why i find your work so
interesting because i think you know as
both matt and i are
left-wing academics um you know um i
think one of the things that's missing
on the left
often is any sort of effort to do
exactly the kind of work that you're
doing which is to really understand
because i
am a firm believer um that if we want to
you know bring people over to our side
we should do a better job of
understanding
what the other side actually thinks and
what's going through their mind and
what's the justification
and i personally think that that
involves and it that necessitates a kind
of humanization of the other side which
i think in some sense is
the work that you're doing um and i
think there's such a temptation to want
to dehumanize so i just
so i think it's a great answer abs
absolutely and and it's it's worth
stating some of the basic
facts of what you just said you said
understanding the other side
that does not mean relativizing yeah
i mean understanding knowing what
they said knowing what happened to them
at x point in their life
those i'm i'm afraid that sometimes
that level of just plain detail
not only is it not known but it's not
sometimes it's not known for a reason
it's not known because it will trouble
the conclusions and the generalizations
that we want to draw
if that's the case the problem is with
your generalizations it cannot be
it can't be with learning more about the
thing you're wanting to talk about
and that's it's i it's it's it's crucial
i will say when it's it's worth
remembering though if
if you're an academic who is committed
also to a political
perspective that when you form
relationships with people i think when
you form relationships
with anybody we can call it
collaboration as we do in in
anthropological and ethnographic theory
but
in in real life what happens when you're
friends with somebody is that
there's often a bit of seating of
control that you
yourself will be changed based on the
relationship and let's hope that you're
the most you can hope for is that you're
honest and aware of that
but what what comes out of that
experience
is is chaos it's a it's a lack of
control
um you seed control and it's one reason
why
i'm i'm a little skeptical of
ethnography for any political purpose
whatsoever
if we're going to practice it in the way
that it has been valued
by ethnographers themselves and also
other disciplines if we're going to
practice it in the way that it produces
some of its signature insights
you should never go into it thinking and
planning on a
particular outcome the experience will
contort your voice you will surrender
some authority
of your texts it's it's it's again
it's chaos um so
this is a soapbox soapbox topic for me
so interesting um
you know actually it brings to mind
another question i had about you know
did you ever have any experiences
of spending time with certain ethnic
nationalists and you know developing a
relationship with them
that then later on they they change
their their views about some things and
and i i the reason i i have this
question is because
have you heard of daryl davis there was
a documentary i think on netflix
yeah okay so you know that story uh yes
right and i think that so that
that story came to mind i actually wrote
an article kind of related to that about
like the importance of humanizing and
compassion and area
um so yeah um so how's that happened
wow first i really want to read your
article but
it has i've been because of some
theoretical debates i've had in academia
i've been reluctant
to put them forward because i don't want
that to be the justification
of course yeah of course i want us to
have a i want us to have an honest
reckoning with our own capabilities as
ethnographers but
yes i've had p this will sound funny
again i've had people call me in the
middle of the night and say
i know the holocaust took place
[Laughter]
wow you know i i mean which was
in this case it was a big deal that was
a you know i was i was actually pretty
shocked to hear that
um i've had i've had people
warm to jewish politicians that they had
not in the past
um i've i've even had in
in one instance i've had a politician
call me up to discuss
an issue in a topic um because they knew
that i had
this was someone that i'd you know i'd
done field work with but i'd also gotten
to know if really well
and they knew where i stood on the issue
and wanted to hear my
hear my perspective and it may have
changed a little bit of something
um and then there are the intangibles
there are people who
have never i think had a lot of
interaction with a jewish person
a an academic a left-leaning academic
and and i knew for me it was shocking to
be able to get along with them
and and i'm fairly certain for them it
was shocking to be able to get along
with me so well and i know that
you know they've spoken about that fact
to some of their friends so i
you know it's i would love to see like a
big dramatic
you know be able to offer you some some
big dramatic conversion story
uh like some of those that we look at
but
short of that there's there's there's
certainly a lot of instances yeah
where where things have changed yeah
well that actually leads me to my last
question
uh which is a bit more of a loaded
question because i'm concerned not with
adjustment
describing things accurately but
sincerely changing hearts and minds as
it were
um so appreciating the fact that that's
not
typically uh the goal of an ethnographer
and i
absolutely agree that that that just
describing has its place and it's a
vital activity
what would you say is the best way of
reaching these people let's just call it
that and getting them to at least
give you the time of day and i'll give
you an example that i engage in as a
theorist right i mean i do a fairly
typical thing which is just
i pick up a book by a conservative
author of seeds make the rounds
and i offer theoretical slash political
criticism of it right
this is what it does well this is what
it does badly blah blah blah hears lots
of detail so you can tell that you know
i've at least taken it seriously
uh overall this is why i think it's
wrong sometimes i actually just i will
say actually i think they get some
things right if it's a really good
thinker like roger scrutin or something
but
usually it's just like this is what's
wrong with it so yes you know
that's the way i approach it but do you
have an alternative or do you think that
there's a different better way
i mean are you speaking about this the
sort of face-to-face contact in
interaction are you speaking more on
that abstract level of ideas
the abstract level of ideas but i'll
leave it to you i'm just kind of curious
about
how you think we could tackle the
problem of winning people over
this getting them to hear us first
taking taking the idea seriously
is key i love that you just said that
the way that that you described it i
mean bear in mind
it would be an amazing feat for someone
to write a book
of pure and total nonsense
that's as much of a challenge as it
would be i think to write the opposite
um or for someone to develop a
philosophy that is 100
ugly evil wrong stupid um so there's
going to be something
there that doesn't mean that we should
just devote ourselves to finding what's
good and ignore
everything else and there's potential
consequences by any means but
um but that's i i would like to see more
of that perspective i think there's an
imbalance especially with people
commenting
on the right on the radical right from
the left
um um so
so there so there's that at the at the
level of ideas
um and it's enough it's a surprise
enough to i think to a lot of these
figures also
to be taken seriously that that can that
can start dialogue and dialogue
is good uh it's
a sappy thing to say but dialogue is
good friendship is good isolation i
think is bad
right yeah i totally agree um but i also
you know they've one thing that i've
seen in sweden a lot of anti-racist
activism that i think is good and and i
don't think it's all good
but some that i think is really good has
invested in localism
um and and treated that as as a sort of
arena where you can actually see
some some collective engagement that
would bring people together that
you know who otherwise are not um
and i you can extrapolate a lot out of
that in
when you meet someone face to face if
you're engaged in
some particular activity or concern or
initiative
you do see our official identities sort
of take a back seat
um and and you can see new bridges
formed and
it doesn't mean that they will stop
being who they were before but you might
find a new parallel
uh relationship or way to speak to
somebody on some issue that didn't exist
before um that's informal it's
unsystemic
unsystematic i would rather say yeah but
but i think it's quite powerful we also
realize that a lot of us are hypocrites
in good and bad ways when you do that if
you if you know drill
down do not massify do not totalize
uh do not invest too much in our
official identities and
and and new things crop up no thank you
that was really helpful
yeah i know for sure actually it's it's
interesting i think uh one of the goals
sort of
of the of the podcast even though we're
definitely on the left is you know to
try to be
um to lit to listen and do justice to
the other side and actually i think
i've noticed it had a couple like some
effect i actually did have someone
contact me
you know on twitter saying you know i'm
i'm sympathetic to richard spencer like
you guys should have them on the show
but you guys are kind of changing my
mind a little bit because you're talking
reasonably so
you know i hope that we'll continue to
to
um to have that goal go forward i
suppose i can tell you i think that is
more important than a million huffington
post
position pieces i i really do it and it
maybe that's not true it just excites me
more it excites me much more too like i
mean that's why i find the daryl davis
story so interesting which i feel like i
should have said
for the listeners because i just kind of
mentioned it you know this he was a
black
blues musician who uh who started
spending time with kkk members and just
talked to them as human beings and
talked about music and his love for
music and he's collected
you know uh you know hundreds of robes
from former kkk members so it's an
incredible story i mean
absolutely and it it reminds us i mean
when you talk about humanizing someone
uh as as you were earlier victor i mean
i mean that
that can sound vapid if if it weren't
for the fact that there was so much
dehumanizing going on and if so many of
our characterizations were not dependent
upon dehumanizing and treating people
like cartoon characters
if you you know if
it's it's like the old the old adage you
know the oh i've you know i've heard of
the guy no he's absolutely not gay he
loves sleeping with men
but no no he's there
there are a lot of people involved in
these circles as well
as well who are there because of
circumstance and they say that they're
on the radical ride they say they're not
on
a neo-nazi because you know because they
believe in these ideas but it actually
has to do with a girlfriend from high
school
right or something like that you're
almost giving it too much credit by by
treating the labels and
and the the exterior as as as stretching
deeper than it may actually
go um and likewise you know on the flip
side of that there are
liberals and explicit anti-racists who
can be pretty damn racist
yeah behind closed doors yeah and i also
i mean
one thing i noticed too is um that
it like you know sort of like anger and
condemnation
it's like a quick fix it's like or it's
like a i often feel like people get a
high from it you know and that's why
it's like both sides
it feels great the left and the right
that righteous indignation like it's
such a drug it's a high
and i feel like like you know this this
this approach which i know your goal is
obviously not to change minds but i
think you know
developing a relationship that's
disruptive of that
i feel like that's disruptive of that
kind of like like you know
uh dialectic of desire and enjoyment
that i think they get
they get from from from condemnation i
should say i think it's also very
difficult today because
the way that a lot of politics is
carried on in social media
tends to reward people who engage in
essentially
disgressive displays uh of what i call a
toxic masculinity but i've also seen
women do it right but
it has this kind of macho quality to it
right where you try to own someone
or you try to essentially destroy them
as the lingua franca now goes
uh and you know i would be lying i've
said that i did take some satisfaction
in that also
watch the average thing of you know dave
rubin just you know getting owned by
this person or whatever but
i really it's certainly not constructive
to the kind of engaged dialogues that
you're calling for
and you know it's not supposed to i'm
calling for it i don't want to put words
in your mouth i'm calling for it at
least
well the when you said mixing stuff up
you said you know taking the dialect it
can just just
mess in with it a little bit oh it
disrupts i think it's disrupting
disrupting i love it i absolutely love
it i mean
i know it's not my official goal to
change
minds but yeah
not in any particular way but i don't
think this is good i do not think
this the hardened positions where we are
all just [ __ ] each other over
you know in the in the best way possible
and to get you know as many likes and
high fives as we possibly can
yeah i i don't believe in that and i and
as an educator i don't like it because
we're i feel like we're getting you know
it makes us stupid
because we we learn less um it's an
exercising of a sort of power to keep
boundaries up between ourselves from
other people
and uh it will make us more ignorant
and it's boring it's bad for society
so i yeah but it but it feels good i do
know that
for sure for sure and i i know i'm
cognizant of time i don't know how much
time you have but i
uh i did have a couple more okay oh i
can stick around a little bit yeah okay
awesome awesome okay good
and since you had lots of other
interviews too i feel bad this has been
by far the most interesting okay for
three days of interviews actually so
awesome that's great um so actually you
know what you were just saying
uh brought to mind i kind of wonder what
your experience as a professor as an
educator has been
with students and who find out about
your work and i know that obviously
student campus groups can be pretty
polarized and angry and i just wonder if
you if you've had any experiences that
you could share with that like positive
and negative
they've it's been exclusively positive
oh okay awesome awesome actually no i
love
all my students but i do there's
no the people who i have trouble with i
think it's telling
people i have trouble with are older
academics
and then center left and center right
journalists
yep i i do okay with the
with most kind of you know
far right i don't know what to call them
really um
uh commentators because they recognize
that i take them seriously to your point
earlier matthew
um and and you can have in-depth
discussions with them and i and i like
that and then
and then you know the activist
progressive left
um has been good too um
i i kind of want to take this in a
different direction if you don't mind
absolutely you know so we're kind of
talking about my book i think it's
telling
the i've gotten some rough reviews from
the center left and the center right
i've gotten some good ones from the
right kind of trump world
but i've gotten almost exclusively
positive reception among the brazilian
left
really you mean like the the lula types
yes yeah
and and that's actually where the book
is doing
best right now it's just just portuguese
it's it's
been easier to promote there than any
place else and i i have a self
self serving narrative about all that
but i think there's there's something to
be said about
about someone who's very invested in the
symbolics of activism
you know do how often do i call steve
bannon a fascist
in the book um you know do i
is my tone sufficiently demonizing
uh throughout the text versus versus
someone
you know like gene willis in brazil
who's been under extreme threat of
course an ally of lula's
um glenn greenwald uh you know people
who are facing
actual tangible threats from the people
that we're talking about
in that is invading their lives and
threatening them in in ways
that you know a journalist in a flat in
london is not being threatened
by them um you know they've looked at
the book and said wow it has taught me
all these things about these people that
i didn't know
um and and
you know perhaps you know forget what
the tone is the the
message of the book and its content is
not flattering of these people
that's what matters and i've learned
something new and that's good
versus you know this
this larping i think that happens from
people who are not actually facing um
you know facing facing a political
threat in in the way that these others
do so
to bring that back to the students i i
feel like you know some of the leftist
organizations on campus
you know i have good relations with with
some of their students they
they like the substance of this you know
i have a lot of them in my classes and
and they
i feel like they're less invent for all
the talk about
cancel culture and and pc mobs the
people more invested
in particulars and who actually want to
do something
uh are it speaks to them
i can speak to the same experience
actually so my most popular class
this last semester i guess now uh was
introduction to the political right
uh and i was quite worried about it
because i've made no bones about it that
like
look we're gonna be looking at fascist
literature we're gonna be looking at
nazi literature like it's important to
understand the far right as well as like
the more
you know sugary centrists you know the
roger scrutin types and
yep i was a little bit concerned because
i've never taught at american university
before and i've heard so much about
cancer culture and how
you're gonna be shouted out but actually
the students i have were really
interested in the stuff
like we really wanted to learn about it
very passionate come to me after class
and they're like you know am i getting
this right
you know what's this whole thing about
mussolini saying this here what does it
mean and all that stuff and
it really perplexed me because i'd heard
so many of the stereotypes about this
but i think it was in part because there
was a real dearth of
literature on the subject or they'd
never really been exposed to some of
these ideas before so naturally they
were interested in them
and i mean i need no bones about it
either i'm like look i'm a kind of
liberal socialist i'm going to be
criticizing this stuff because i think
it's wrong but we're going to take it
seriously and we're going to
try to unpack what the appeal of it is
uh i got a lot of papers at the end
where people would say
like look like there's a kind of core to
some of this that might be appealing
it's just distorted or it's
misplaced or any different things so
it's really interesting to me as a
social experiment just to see that
a lot of the stereotypes i had about
left-wing students
was deeply wrong you know this is my own
experience
yes i think that
i think also a lot of see i don't say
that to them i keep my students in the
dark the whole time
i do my best and i tell them this class
will offend them i tell them if
you're looking for trigger warnings
write it over the entire syllabus
everything is a trigger warning
yeah i'm not going to bring you back to
earth at the end of each lecture
what's the plus you know
what's the class like oh radical
nationalism and global neo-fascism i
suppose the title is kind of out you
know not quite as
as as as i don't have as much in my ice
in my stomach as
as i would like to as swedes say it's
not quite as as
as dry but um but one thing that i think
that they all like
you know the conservative republican
students like it but the
left-wing students do too is that i'm
not
i'm going to treat them like adults i'm
going to give them this literature
and i'm going to trust them to
to interpret it it's not the same thing
as saying
believing in you know in balance which
is a concept that i hate
right or in neutrality it's saying that
you know if we want to learn about this
we want to learn about it well
it's going to take our full attention oh
yeah and
and if if you say that you know what i
trust you to do that and i trust that
you're not going to walk out of this
classroom and start
you know start another holocaust
it's it's empowering to them um so it's
those have been my most successful
classes
at cu it got rate it got rated atop in a
kind of a student
publication it was really really the top
class on campus uh
that's awesome wow that's awesome
absolutely it's been a delight to do
yeah it's funny earlier you were
mentioning those some of those the
reviews i mean i did take a look online
and you must be thinking i think it was
in the guardian and i remember reading
it and i was just like holy crap this
guy's an [ __ ] like i don't know
he he he gave you a [ __ ] for calling
steve's bannon steve
or something like that i was like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
yeah it was ridiculous i was like does
this guy care about i don't know it was
yeah so
i was outraged on your behalf oh yeah
well i i appreciate i really appreciate
that
victor the interesting thing i i hear so
often
um again from that sector the center
left or center right or
older kind of establishment academics at
the end of their careers is
you know they'll read my work i know
that it's something new for them say
traditionalism
you know as it was for the the
journalists and the guardian luke
harding
um you know so i know he learned new
things from reading the book
and they get to the end of it like oh my
gosh this is so unbelievably dangerous
and then they turn around and turn to me
and say you didn't explain just how
dangerous this is
and if someone is in that state of mind
you know two things are either
one of two things is true either they
think that
other people are not capable of the same
inferences that they are capable of
right um or or their interest is really
in me
you know it's not is the book going to
explain to people
and show people how dangerous these
ideas are because obviously they are
unless unless this person has powers of
perception that
us mere mortals don't have you know then
it's just about me and then who cares so
it
it's it's an observation that came and
came in that in that review that was
just like
to me it's transparently stupid oh yeah
totally where are you i'm kind of
curious about some i know you mentioned
like positive reactions to the book
just gonna ask quickly like what what
reaction steve bannon had to the book if
he was happy with it that was
well he i mean he thought that his
sections were
were faithful at least to what he said
and thought um he hasn't
told me that he's read the whole book
even though i'm sure he has because he
does that sort of thing
but um you know so he he gave me that
alexander dugan liked it olavo de
carvalho
in brazil did not like it he seemed like
a crank anyway though
oh no he has you know and he has a huge
social media following so he has
he has released videos that have gotten
like hundreds of thousands of likes you
know that are titled like ben title
bound the liar
and oh wow it's you know really all over
the place but
that's that's a whole nother that would
take another podcast he was the ice
cream fan right yes
nice memory yes wow you know that it was
very vividly described right let's just
put it there
okay cool and then i guess like just
just closing up i was just kind of
curious if there's anything i know we
covered a lot of stuff but um
if there's anything that you feel like
in other interviews you know you don't
get a chance to talk about that you
think is really important to take away
from the book
if you want to add something like that
oh gosh i mean you
you both are pretty attuned to the kind
of the intellectual history
and the intellectual profiling of
traditionalism so that
that's a really refreshing um
alternative here i
you know people who are more interested
in the journalistic aspect of it i i
i wish more people would latch on to the
story of jason giorgiani
and the woman um in the book because
even though it's not as much of a news
item and we're not dealing with people
who were successful
not that you know bannon and dugan i
think it's up in the air
whether or not they're successful uh
that that
storyline was pretty pretty uh
gosh was it overwhelming for me to study
and follow
my editor didn't really want to put it
in but i was i was just just taken with
it
so i would encourage you if your your
listeners to pay attention to that
that too okay awesome thanks so much for
coming on this was a real pleasure
yeah i had a great time and i really
learned a lot from your book and uh
hopefully our review will come out
pretty soon in jack ben and uh you know
i'll let you a few more readers but
it deserves it deserves a wide audience
totally
i really appreciate that you both and
best best of which is it's a pleasure to
talk to you and best of wishes in your
academic careers too
thanks so much later take care bye
[Music]